فكره جديده مبتكره لمحاربه سرطان الجلد
تقوم على انتاج جلد الصناعي لاختباره ومنه
يمكن دراسه وقف تمدد الخلايا السرطانيه
الخبيثه هذا الجل الاصطناعي اقرب ما يمكن
لبشره الانسان الحقيقيه بخلايا الجلديه
مزروعه من ماده الكولاجين
بحسب ما جاء في مجله ساين سيغنينج فانه
جرى اختبار بعضها على البشر وبعدها قيد
الاختبار فيما يتعلق
في الباحثون وهم علماء في جامعه كوبنهاجن
سعوا في دراستهم الى معرفه ما يحدث على
وجه التحديد عندما تتحول خليه طبيعيه الى
سرطانيه وكيفيه السيطره عليها
يقول علماء في جامعه كوبنهاجن ان دراستهم
حول الجلد الاصطناعي تهدف الى معرفه ما
يحدث عندما تصبح الخلايا الطبيعيه سرطانيه
العلماء بحثوا في مسار اشارات تطلقه خلايا
تسمى مسار كي جي اف بيتا يلعب المسار دورا
في كيفيه التواصل الخلايا مع محيطها
والتحكم في نمو الخلايا وانقسامها اذا
تعطلت هذه الاليات تصبح الخليه سرطانيه
وتغزو الانسجه المحيطه في الظروف العاديه
لا تغزو خلايا الجلد الطبقه تحت الجلد
لانها تكون طبقه جديده ولكن مع ظهور
الخلايا السرطانيه تبدا في الغزو وتظهر في
النهايه او تظهر في النهايه سلوكا يسمى
النمو الغازي العلماء درسوا هذا المسار
وطبقوا اساليب مختلفه لوقف هذا النمو
الخبيث وبالفعل وجدوا العديد من الادويه
تستطيع سد هذه المسارات وبعضها كيدو البحث
[موسيقى]
الباحث في جامعه نيويورك ابو ظبي والمتخصص
في الهندسه البيولوجيه دكتور كاميه للخوري
دكتور يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في
الاستوديو شكرا على تواجدك معنا صباح
الخير لالكم للمتابعين كلهم طيب دكتور
عندما نتحدث عن انتاج جلد اصطناعي قادر
على منع تمدد الخلايا السرطانيه الى طبقات
الجلد نتحدث عن اهميه هذا الابتكار وما هو
الجلد الاصطناعي للناس اللي عم تشوفنا كيف
يمكن ترويضه طبيا بالبدايه قبل ما ابدا
بالجلد الاصطناعي لازم نشرح شو متكون هاي
الجلد هو متكون من طبقات وتلات طبقات
اساسيه للجلد يعني عنا البشره للتحمينا من
كل شيء خارج وما يفوت لجوا الطبقه الثانيه
فيها الاوعيه الدمويه اللي بتغذي البشره
وكل باقي الجلد واخر طبقه فيها الدهون
اللي هي بتحمل
الاعضاء الداخليه من اذا صار صدمه او صار
غيره فبس بدنا نيجي ندرس بالمختبر الجلد
ما فينا نفصل بس طبقه واحده عن البقيه
فينا ندرسوا بالعاده
كنا ندرس هون على مسطحات بلاستيكيه فبس
فينا ندرس جزء من طبقه واحده بهاي الحاله
استعملوا هول العلماء كلها هي ماده موجوده
كتير بجسمنا اكثر بروتين موجود وحطوا هول
خلايا بقلبوا طبقات الجلد اللي هي بتمثل
حقيقه شو موجود بجسم الانسان من خلالها
درسوا مسارات بتكونها الخلايا لتصير خلايا
سرطانيه وبتعمل غزوه لباقي الطبقات لانه
بالعاده الخلايا الموجوده بطبقه ما مفروض
تغذي الطبقه الثانيه بس خليها السرطانيه
ما عندها هيدا ما عندها هيدا السلوك
بتتمدد وبتنتشر
تمدد الخلايا السرطانيه بس مش بنقدر نقول
علاج لسرطان الجلد يعني كعلاج فوري لا مش
علاج هن هن درسوها لانه اكتشفوا بهول
المسارات بس بس يتفعل هو بيوقف هذا التمدد
فيوقف هذا التمدد ايوه
نوع من الحلول هو يمكن بالسرطان يتم
توقيفه لهذا المسار اعاده تفعيل واعطاء
ادويه لاعاده تفعيله فهون الخليه
السرطانيه ما بتقعد تتمدد بباقي الطبقات
الجلديه بنوقف من انتشار وللسرطان طيب
الخلايا الصناعيه مصنوعه كما قلت من
الكولاجين هل هذا سيجعلها تماما مثل بشره
الانسان الطبيعيه تنمو وحتى اذا صار في
جروح يمكن ان تعالج هو هذا الشيء مزبوط
لانه هلكولاجين بخلينا ننتقل من المسطحات
البلاستيكيه الثنائيه الابعاد
لسلاسي الابعاد وهون كمان تلعب كتير دور
اللي هي عم تطلع عن جديد الطباعه ثلاثيه
الابعاد باستعمال الحبر الحيوي والبيولوجي
فاذا بس ندرس شيء بطبقه ثلاثيه الابعاد
بيعطينا حقيقه موجود بالجسم واكتشفوا
العالم ما بخلال غير ابحاث انه الخلايا
بتتفاعل بغير طريقه بس تكون موجوده
بطبقه ثلاثيه الابعاد عن ثنائيه الابعاد
كرمال هيك من قبل كان الادويه يتم
اختبارها واختباره يوصل
فكره احسن ومطابقه للجسم البشري
هل نتخصص في مساله هذه التقنيه او هذه
الطريقه المبتكره هل يمكن توظيفها في
مساله الاغراض التجميليه يعني مش بس علاج
يعني شخص مثلا بده بشره افضل بشره اصغر
ممكن طبعا طبعا في في ابحاث عم بتصير بهذا
المجال مش بس هيك في ناس بيتعرضوا لحروق
وبيصحوا منه وبيصير عندهم تشوهات فينا
نستعمل هالطبقه من الكولاجين مع الخلايا
الموجوده بقلبها لحل هيدي المشاكل وطبعا
هول الخليه شو اهميهم بس نقول عم نستعمل
خلايا لانه بيجوا منها نحن مناخذ خزعه
والخلايا بطبيعتها بتتقاسم بتتكاثر
فمنقسمهم منقاتلهم بالمختبر ومنحطهم
بالكولاجين منزرعهم بالبشره مطابقين 100%
للخليه لانه هن الخيال الخلايا الموجوده
بقلب جسمنا وهنا اهميه هذا بيقولوا لهلا
الشخصي طب من ناحيه الطبيه في حال تنفيذ
هذه الاليه على جسم الانسان الى اي مدى هي
عمليه سلسه زراعه جلد اصطناعي في الانسان
طبعا هي طبعا هي هي التنفيذ سلس ممكن يكون
سلس المشكله بالتطوير انه بياخد وقت لانه
بدنا ناخذ الخليه بدنا نطورها بالمختار
انه نعمل لها نتاكد انه ما تحولت لخلايا
السرطانيه بدنا بدنا
نفبرك الكولاجين الماده نتاكد انه كل شيء
معقم وبعدين يتم زراعتها من خلال جراحين
على فهي المشكله
الفرق بين ما مفروض يبين لا الكوست كبيره
والوقت طويل فاذا منقدر نلاقي طريقه ممكن
يكون من خلال
طباعه رئيسه الابعاد فنقلل المده ونقلل
الكوست وتكون كل شيء اوتوميتد يعني هل
ممكن يكون حل هذا الموضوع وعلى امل دائما
في هذه الثوره العلاجيه في كل شيء شكرا
جزيلا لكم الباحث في جامعه نيويورك ابو
ظبي والمتخصص في الهندسه البيولوجيه كميل
خوري شكرا شكرا لالكم على الاستضافه شكرا
للاستاذ وسام ولكل ولكل الطاقم العمل